-Amanda, it is so lovely
to see you again.
Thank you so much
for being here.
-Thank you so much
for having me.
-It must be -- I think it's
strange time for all of us
It must be a little weird to b
talking about a television sho
you made before any of
this started happening.
-It is very weird and awkward,
and maybe we should talk
about other things.
-Yes. But I will say that
I know a lot of people
that are running out of grea
television to watch,
and so I do think
it's important that you know
that you're also providing
a service.
-Thank you very much
for saying that.
-Is it your --
Your sister is a doctor,
and her husband, as well, in
Philadelphia right now.
Have you been --
You must be fairly impressed
with what they're pulling off.
-Yes. I have been --
First, I was very worried
in the beginning,
when they were both --
You know, they both go
through -- They're on servic
for certain weeks and
then at home for certain weeks
And, at first,
I was very nervous,
but then I always
have to remember
that they do really know exactly
what they're doing.
My brother-in-law is
actually infectious diseases
He's an infectious-disease
doctor and pediatrician.
So he's really --
Usually, he's researching poop
but now he's being...
Yeah, microbiome research,
but now he's being inundated
with COVID calls,
especially from us.
-You know things are bad
when you're upset
to be pulled away from
your poop research.
-Yes. Exactly.
-The last time
you were on the show,
we talked about the fact tha
your three children
are not particularly impressed
with your career as an actor
And, yet, you do
want to take some time today
to say that you have been
incredibly impressed
with their teachers through this
incredible time
we're living through.
-Yeah. I mean,
I feel like there's been
a vacuum in terms of
presidential leadership.
And I guess I felt like,
from day one, when we were -
David and I were sort of
discussing whether Frankie
my 13-year-old,
was old enough to watch
the full video of George Floyd
And by the time
we had made our decision
and came to her and sat down
she was like,
"Oh, yeah, I already watched i
in my core class."
And her teachers were taking -
were filling that vacuum.
And then my sister and I
have been sending
back-and-forth letters
from heads of school
that are very
moving and inspiring.
And, in fact,
my sister sent me a note
from my nephew's head of school,
who was requiring
school-wide homework for
everyone to watch
the Trevor Noah video.
So we watched that as a family
And, yeah, I think they've jus
taken that role of leadership,
and it's been
incredibly comforting
and inspiring and a huge relief.
-Yeah, it is very nice to know
your children
are in safe hands,
and we feel very lucky, as well,
as parents through this time
-And also in addressing it
you know, instead of sort of
side-stepping it.
It seems like they --
You know, we were sort of --
We were so -- I think we wer
overly cautious,
and they were like, you know
"Discuss, discuss, discuss."
And I feel like
one of the things
in the Trevor Noah video,
the sort of --
the essay that he did,
was talking about how,
you know, it took George Floyd
the George Floyd video
and the fact that
he was actually murdered
in broad daylight and
it was filmed
and it was in public,
for us to start discussing
systemic racism.
And I feel like
both my kids' schools
and my nephew and nieces'
schools in Philadelphia
have just been -- They're just
going right into it,
right into the conversation.
-Yeah, a lot of friends of min
who have slightly older kids
have also spoken about that.
It was a really powerful,
really moving video by Trevo
that also, I think, spoke abou
the social contract, in a way,
that I don't feel like peopl
have spoken about that
eloquently.
So I also --
-Yeah, I thought it was
really important
that he was saying that,
you know,
people in positions of privilege
and power, including Trump
can't dictate
the terms of the protest.
That's, you know, antithetical
to the idea of protests.
We're actually protesting
the status quo.
We're trying to upend
the current hierarchies
in which we're entrenched in -
in which we're entrenched.
You can cut that out.
-I do want to talk about -
This is Season 2
of "Dirty John."
It was based on a true story
You're playing a real person
Betty Broderick.
It does strike
me as this must be --
must have been an exhausting
character to play,
to some degree, because of how
emotionally taxing it is,
knowing that it was
a real story,
knowing both what this woman did
and what she went through
that led her to that moment.
When you took it on, did you put
a lot of thought into
what you were about to
embark on?
-Yeah. I mean, we knew that it
was probably going to be
a really intense schedule,
and so we did have a little --
We had a family meeting
to explain to the kids
that I was going to be
pretty much gone
13 hours a day for three months.
And, so, yeah, David stepped in,
and, you know,
he did all of
the parent-teacher conferences
and soccer uniforms
and soccer games.
And anytime there was any
griping, I was like,
"Dude, nine years
of 'Game of Thrones.'"
-Yes. For anyone
who doesn't know...
-It's your turn.
-...your husband was one o
the co-creators of
"Game of Thrones,"
which I imagine, like,
took up some time.
I imagine being behind
the camera for that show
took up some time.
-Let's just say there were -
I did several parent-teacher
conferences on my own.
So it was about time
he took the lead.
-Well, I'm glad that he steppe
up and did his part.
-He really did.
-It's always so lovely
to see you.
Please give my love to David
and your family.
-Thank you.
He sends his back to you.
-And I hope to see you
in person soon.
-Me too. Be well.
-And to you.